il n'a que 17 ans l'âge des soldats qui
sont partis au front en 1914
malgré sa jeunesse le fontenaisien léon
dubois est passionné par l'histoire de
la première guerre mondiale
la der des der il a mis en scène une
exposition j'ai réussi à retrouver le
sable de mon arrière-grand-père arrière
arrière grand père dans le grenier de
mes grands parents qu'il a dès 1916 et
voilà et donc c'est comme ça que c'est
n'est vraiment mon fils au fur et à
mesure des recherches et de ses enfants
apprenaient attiré 14 18 donc la der des
ders une guerre à laquelle on croit au
départ la guerre ensuite de toutes les
désillusions
c'est cet état d'esprit du soldat du
poilu que retrace le jeune homme en 14
on est dans l'illusion clairement on est
dans l'illusion d'une guerre courte et
on sent invincible en fait et ça c'est
cdu à l'éducation que les soldats ont
reçu que les enfants ont reçu toute leur
jeunesse ils j'excuse expose un fusil
scolaire les années 1915 1916 où une
sorte de normalisation du conflit c'est
à dire qu'on fait avec
et puis 10 917 doute l'exposition marque
un tournant
même au niveau géographique à
l'exposition il ya un tournant et
1917 voilà c'est les mutineries et là on
commence à comprendre une lassitude un
désespoir qui s'installe
j'ai un lot de correspondance et dans
cette correspondance de soldats qui ont
été tuées le même jour du même au but et
il s'avérait que ces deux soldats
étaient du même village du même âge
qu'ils avaient fait leurs écoles leurs
classes ensemble voilà ils ont été tuées
le même jour par le même but et des
choses assez terrible faire vivre le
devoir de mémoire sensibiliser sur les
drames de la guerre
l'enjeu pour léon dubois c'est la
transmission ça nous remet en mémoire
nos ancêtres enfin certains d'entre eux
qui est ont connu la guerre justement
pour moi ça représente quelque chose
d'un peu particulier parce que j'ai mon
grand père paternel qui est plus de ce
monde qui a laissé une partie de sa
figure en 1917
c'est une gueule cassée alors oui oui
oui objets d'époque témoignages une
exposition richement documentée à
découvrir jusqu'au 17 novembre en mairie
de fontenay le fleury léon dubois est
régulièrement présent pour renseigner la
semaine prochaine le jeune homme
reprendra ses cours à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en première
année d'histoire logique qu'on me
demande qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus
tard
j'ai l'habitude de répondre j'attends
pas plus tard pour le faire par la
système c'est à dire que voilà que je
fais ce que je suis en capacité de faire
maintenant et après on verra à quoi ça
me mènera